okay
people joining this live stream we are
doing
an incremental language development
meeting that
i guess is uh working on things
for version 12.3 of watson language and
beyond
so variety of things revised based
themes
yes so these are notebooks that chris
sent after
our meetings a lot better yeah it's ones
that i sent chris this morning
oh i see i see okay these look great tim
i mean okay
and if you click previous you can see
what the previous one was no i don't
want to see that
i just really toned them down and got
rid of the bold text
and what lists up there what i did has
has jeremy looked at these no
yeah i think these titles are a little
funky but the the look is
vastly vastly better yeah the time i'm
going to be changing
with the next plot theme
i'm going to be changing web uh
marketing business
and scientific right and come up with
new names
and right but i'm i'm telling you tim i
think what you should do
you've been designing to those names i
think you should leave those names
and [ __ ] off another name okay yeah
and and maybe that other name will be
largely informed by what you have from
these things
but not completely yeah okay
okay and these are just mock-ups
the um like
the text the item text is all black
and well that's good if chris was going
to change that because
that's what that's the i think that's
why it looks so bad yesterday is because
the item text was great well right he
needs to change that if he can
is chris here i don't
know he's not no he's not here
but they just let him know about the
meeting of one so
okay right okay look
looking good all right what's next
um well uh nothing
more in relation to dataset team well i
i i don't know i mean there's a lot to
do but i think in terms of getting this
version out
i think this is looking fine okay well
yeah i was asking them so
if if nothing else about dataset then
them they both can leave if
they want okay
okay so the next thing to do is as usual
in the last moment in a cycle is
knitting
so we have the non-three functions
for which we have already done the basic
c also knitting in both directions
including from other system functions
but we have not added them yet to guide
pages
and then we have three for which we have
the collection of new symbols which are
28
and four new guide pages okay
and in this case we have the symbols
linked to each other
but they are not yet linked from
anywhere else in the system
and because they are so experimental
perhaps
we should leave them like that in this
first version i'm sorry what
leave what so the fact that for example
graph
functions do not yet link to the three
symbols
well do they connect to them
connect not yet so the three symbols
link to the graph functions but not vice
versa
so it is that this project is
highly experimental so i don't know
what's the right level of publicity we
want in this first version
what do you mean by highly experimental
uh well the the functionality works of
course but for example visualization is
not yet as good as
it should be we did fix the basic
styling yes
uh it has the proper colors etc but
sizes
uh sizes are still not good enough so
so things like nodes with overlap will
overlap very small
trees will have padding around like
graphs do
etc okay
um
do you want to have a look at some
concerns
um right let's go ahead
um yeah so um
yeah what should we look at um
we could look at some pages or do the
knitting
or okay let's do this basic knitting
here yep
okay uh i have no idea what's a
comparable
for this one for the psychographic order
we could compare
to alphabetical order and numerical
order
okay
which is so would this be under
so that's only under string operations
i see so this should be the equivalent
should be list manipulations
yeah we don't want uh right
lexicographic ordering next string
okay it does work so
we decided that lexicographic order on
two strings will convert to the list of
their characters
okay i have to make this bigger but but
um
let's just find whether it belongs here
uh well to probably be rearranging and
restructuring lists right
yeah exactly
okay here we go alphabetic sort
numerical sort
okay um
[Music]
okay so what do we got we've got
lexicographic sort
and lexicographic order
so perhaps we just add them to the list
of the sort functions
yeah but we've got reverse sort by here
oh i'm sorry we've got the ordering
functions well where are the order
functions here
right these are order functions not sort
functions right
oh they've got like graphics source yeah
it's always up there
okay so so we should add like a graphic
sort right here
exactly yeah i think so
um okay so then we've also got numerical
order
under where that shows up
weird okay numerical order is showing up
there in alphabetical order well where
where do we think lexicographic orders
should show up
yeah it's interesting apparently we
don't have an order
guide page we probably should have one
we probably should have one
right um
because there's all kinds of sorting and
ordering functions
uh indeed where would it hang off
perhaps off here
yes i think so
[Music]
um
ordering lists what's oh that's a
tutorial never mind
ah boy
[Music]
okay where is order covered
there's order on this page
it's not useful
where is it
um i don't understand where where does
the order function what guide page does
the order function appear on
uh
i am very confused here oh wait a minute
well let's look at um
order see alphabetical is just going to
show up on the pages
that are about alphabetic
we have one guide called testing
expressions
but it's okay is that relevant to this
well it contains order
and actually order is marked there as
primary so
maybe i see
yeah i hadn't realized we certainly need
a
i think that that's something i mean i
could try to suggest for next week
okay well here let's let's understand
where to put this
why the heck is order even on here the
variant
right under there right 12 2.
well maybe we should list here um
let's let's list all the orders here
lexicographic order
numerical order is it no numerical order
right
yes and alphabetical order right
okay
okay
uh right what else are we doing here
string take drop
yes so these should go either string
manipulation or string operations
or both okay well let's look where
string takers
um
yeah we should be using our own
technology for these searches especially
since this doesn't seem to work
help how do i find this
i don't understand what this is doing
yeah i mean
i i usually like to do these things with
you because this
this tool works so well um
but i i can see a string take in both
string manipulation and string
operations i think i just had to restart
this and now it
now it does better okay okay
well i don't know if it really does
better let's see guides
uh string manipulation and string
operations okay
okay let's take a look at string
operations
we've got string part string
[Music]
it feels less important than string
yes i mean we have string taken stick
drop there but
um
here it could go with that with a pear
you could put a triple there
yeah all right
i don't know how to get this to work
actually
like okay somebody's got to fix that
yeah i will fix that
okay all right now do we need to put it
in the other place here
i think we should because this is sort
of a complete list of string operations
okay okay
and then there is number digit
okay which is uh
so that goes with integer digits and
also goes with all the number theory
stuff and so on
i assume you've got you've got the cross
links from integer digits and so on
right yes we did
um well there's a whole one on number
digits
and let's pull up number digits
representation of numbers
number theoretical functions
integer functions oh it's not
i mean is it interesting for number
theoretic or integer functions
i think so i think it's a thing people
people okay let's start with number
digits okay
so is digits real digits from digits so
we should probably describe this
so it gets the nth digit of a number
right
the power 10 to the n okay the digit of
the power 10 to the m
um
let's put it here
okay
objections to that seem okay to you
yeah perfect
okay digit representations it really
definitely goes here
it goes there as some number digit
actually
yeah i think it goes there okay
okay um
representations of numbers
i think we should put it in here
okay
and integer digits does it go here at
all
digit-related functions we've got so
many places where we talk about
digit-related functions
right
i kind of think in this collection it
probably goes
before digit count
okay okay all right
we did our knitting there okay let's
keep going
[Music]
um
okay what's next tree
yes so as i was saying i'm not sure the
level of
knitting that we want to do in this
first iteration
let me see the pages where uh i mean
oh why don't we link even if we don't
crosslink
from every you know we should at least
do a see also
from the uh whatever it is guide pages
from the graph guide pages to these
guide pages
okay
so if you want to have a look at i don't
know tree itself or something like that
so most of the functions we have in this
first iteration are the structural
functions like the extraction tree
extract
tree size so we have implemented the new
greenish color yeah let's let's let me
just look at these
i'm just going to so i need to run this
on the 12 3 head branch
uh yes but it doesn't yet have the green
color
you will see branch
the prototype has the green color okay
um
okay let's see um
prototype is taking forever to launch
is it hello prototype application not
responding okay it finally did
okay magnificently green
ah almost like that come at the frog
thing anyway never mind um
do you think it's too much no i don't i
think it's okay i
i think these are a little bit inelegant
for some reason i think that um
uh let me just so if i say if i make an
expression
and then i say expression graph no
expression
tree oh wow
okay that's cool that's nice it's much
better than tree form
isn't it i mean we should turn treeform
into this
i i think the only thing i'm having a
hard time with is the heaviness of those
borders which i don't remember
i don't know the history of that what do
you know about that ian
doesn't look right to me i
i can take another look at it could you
check that it follows the spec
because i don't think it's right okay
um i'm just curious what happens if we
go much bigger here
um right i was actually thinking that
this was a fortunate case
okay if it is very big or very small
then i think yeah it has more
of that type of problem
and what determines the overall aspect
ratio here
what about graph plot does so this is
based on graph plot
internally
right and i believe it's right i believe
it's automatic right it lays them out
and then depending on how wide versus
how tall your tree is overall
that sort of right you can see that it's
keeping layers
straight so it's yeah how many layers
versus how wide they are that determines
the aspect ratio
but so if i were to say expression tree
of this and i would just say an aspect
ratio here
does that work i don't think it does
no no we don't take
visualization options yet okay okay
so you probably should and i mean in
this case here the overall
size is pretty goofy too
i don't think you probably thought about
that and this is probably the default
overall size
yes but basically here it's everything
is default we have tried some heuristics
but it's it's very difficult to get all
right right yeah and
and thus far the heuristics are doing
things like
cutting things off so i think it's
better to have something that's squished
that you can make bigger
than oh sure yeah but i i guess my
question is doesn't graph have a
heuristic
based on the number of nodes in the
graph what the overall size is
this should do something like that i
think it does but here we have the added
problem
of the labels of the of the texts
and and that's that's hard problem it's
the same hard problem we have in geo
having to worry about collisions etc
i understand um but at the very least
we could get some i see what you're
saying so if you say
how do i get rid of all the labels here
is there a good way to do that
um do tree map
null ampersand
yep
okay right and i think the issue is that
graph assumes each one of those vertices
is a small
dot and so it picked a good size for
that
and it doesn't know about the labels
overwriting
but i mean i would like to turn this
into a pure tree in which there's no
you know in which there's no actual
payload anywhere
right how do i do that if this was a
pure tree
these things would just appear because
it's not these things here should just
be dots well
then we can change the shape of a
of a vertex that contains null but
that's what a pure tree is
it's a tree where the data is null i
thought we had a different design for
the case where there is nothing
at a particular vertex graphic design
yes um
i didn't follow this enough to know
whether
that's true or not but i'm pretty sure i
remember that we had a version where
there was just a pure dot here
similarly here we can ask billy
okay fine but i mean i think you are
sorry i think you are referring to a
design in the previous iteration
long ago i mean as i think we have
discussed that
with em for example
but certainly we can yeah i think we i
think we should do that because i think
this should be a pure tree with just
dots
basically just like just like graph
nodes
i remember we also discussed the
possibility of for example having that
special dot when
when it is list so it's a very frequent
case in which you have a list with
kind of what kind of list when we have
nested lists
rather than having a head list
i i'm trying to think when we have
discussed having a dot and i remember
you know interesting that the
representation
list could be a lot i didn't understand
where lists sharpet here at all i mean
so if we had the nest at least imagine
something like groupings
and which there are many lists
so let's say i say one two three yeah
f oops
no no they just say two or three or
something two
o two yeah right okay so here we have
all these nested lists
and rather than representing all these
things with so many lists
so if i say expression tree here
right exactly oh yeah that's horrible
so so so i think you're starting to
appreciate why jose called this highly
experimental
yes the visualization part is certainly
the part which is most lacking
okay so in this case
i mean if i somewhat bizarrely in
percent 12 i just replace the list with
null
oh that's it
yeah yeah did you get that
yep okay so expression tree of
12 and i say tree map
of your null ampersand trick
yeah that's pretty horrible that really
should be just small dots
i mean it'll look lovely when it goes to
full size but it looks wrong right now
right yeah so sizes are an issue both on
this side
of of the very large and on the other
side of the very small
you mean a tree that is just just do
three of um
yeah something very small
right yeah that looks wrong too but i
mean we got that right for graph
so so ian you should be able to get from
charles the the heuristics that they've
used for graph
to avoid that case right because if i
make the graph a graph like that
um
hmm that's wrong if
wasn't this just changed by default
yeah wrong graph is supposed to be
smaller by default for a case like that
i thought we'd manage to get that right
that's another thing needs to be looked
at okay
because again if i resize this i'm
resizing
both the overall size of the graph and
that is resizing these dots to be
smaller and it should be this size of
dot
in this overall size of graph and by the
way notice you've got a
a slice off there
so as i was saying before we inherit all
the problems that graph has
plus all the issues related to labels
the for example the fact that we have to
come we will have to compute
size sizes of all these boxes like we do
in geo
yeah i understand i understand even on
our live stream is
pointing out that trees need collision
detection which isn't hard
yeah it's a lot easier than it is for
general graphs
um and it is true that i mean we have
i mean you know the algorithm is
obviously
you know the the algorithm coming up
from from depth first
you know coming up from the bottom of
the tree is not difficult to accumulate
that but the tree will not look as nice
in other words if we take a tree like
this
right it's not completely obvious what
you want to do in terms of the angles
and so on in the case where you are
simply maximally avoiding
i mean you're just going to accumulate i
guess i guess this is a
yes we do need that we do need that i
mean we
at what point do we know how big these
things are well the very the very first
thing is computing the size of each
object and this is a difficult thing
because we have to take into account
the fonts the styling it's the very same
thing
in geo and it's the part that takes the
most time because the front end is not
very friendly in reporting sizes
and so we have to rasterize and do
things like that right although
i mean there are improvements to current
valve to absolute current value
that are somewhere in 12 30 and i think
some are still coming which may or may
not
may or may not help i'm just saying that
the front end is
is working on that aspect of it right i
mean the issue being we just don't know
how big these things are until we
actually know the pixelated font
rendering
which depends on the platform which
depends on the front end right
and so many parameters because style we
can put styles around
all these things and they will all
affect right
um right
let's see uh there's a comment from dan
again i can't parse these names properly
but
dan dot dot dot notice that shortest
path function doesn't have a summary box
what is shortest path
where is shortest path what is that
looks like it's a oh oh you mean oh i
see what you're saying
that's interesting that's a good point
thank you
that's a good point is that
well that may just be an oversight or is
there a confirmation
that hasn't been reevaluated recently
well let's find out it's an oversight
it's an oversight thank you very much
go fix it yeah terrific thanks
um
how did we miss that or what process
would not it would have caused us not to
miss it
well what version was this new in uh if
it was if it was new
sorry go ahead if it was uh
uh new and
conversion una so that means it was less
than
my original list so my hunting around
and asking people
somehow failed to produce this so
that's how it was missed okay
well you know one thing we could do if
we search the documentation for the
horror
of um uh you know
wait a minute this is fine shortest path
sorry shortest path function
uh 2010 8.0 okay
if we sort if somebody maybe we can ask
the
documentation team to do this to just
search for this abomination
well except that's not the only possible
abomination but it's easy enough to
search for such things
okay anyway well thanks to to down there
um
okay let's see comments from ethan about
annealing and constraint based
optimizers can handle laying out trees
with arbitrary sizes labeled
yeah i don't think we have a problem the
problem is just determining the sizes
once we know the sizes i think we can
manage it
do we agree or is there i mean i think
we were able to do it for the much more
complicated case
of geo layout correct right yes
so so it's just really a question of
getting the sizes
yeah we can program the algorithm but
but what's taking the
most time is the competent sizes right
okay so what are we going to do with
trees so basically what we're agreeing
it looks like we could have trees
hold on let's let's let's consider the
following possibility
um
where is it
hmm i mean the possibility would be
to actually have
you see eventually we're just going to
want a thing called trees here
i would think a top-level link called
trees
do you agree eventually yes
i'm just asking whether right now is the
best time to do it i mean perhaps
charles and roger
would have to right and how else we're
going to link it
i'm not sure that's why i was suggesting
that perhaps this very first version we
just don't have them
here but we'll never be able to find
them there
well they'll be in the new features
they'll be
if you just search for trees you'll find
them
right all right okay look put them in
the related guides down here but but we
need to not forget
that we're goofing this up
you know once they're ready for prime
time we need to make sure they're
properly promoted here
and as i say we definitely need to have
a trees section
down here right
okay okay fine all right
comment on our live stream from andrew
would it be possible to create an
operator similar to outside
slash that would instead by default pipe
into the first argument requiring only
additional arguments to be given
um okay for example
i see let's take a look at this
interesting interesting all right let's
take a look
so the thought here
see the problem is any time it looks
like this
anytime we actually have a thing
where it has the wrong number of
arguments i think we're in
we're toast in effect
the operator form
well okay so right i mean that's right
that's you just do
slash pound and put an ampersand at the
end right
yes but well except for the precedent by
the way i just want to report that this
raft is having it's it's it's some
bottom uh um
cut off yeah frame cut off um
right but the right but uh but the but
the precedence works in that case the
precedence is completely correct
for for that case i do that sort of
thing all the time so what do you say
in the yeah one two three four five
splash
slash put a pound
put your second arg and then
ampersand right that precedence will
work fine
so i'm not sure why we need a special
operator for or
for this no i agree this works this
works but now does it
and if you want to pipe it i mean
clearly if you want to it'll it'll keep
piping right
right
yeah i think that i think this can work
i mean i think the
yeah i mean the only thing that i could
sort of maybe
conceivably imagine but i don't think it
makes sense
is an auto functioning
thing here but i don't think it will
make sense i think it'll be a mess
it'll be too hard to understand when
it's going to do that so i would say i
would say i think this is
in fact working um
operator applied could be also used
slash slash operator applied of
f of two
okay let me just understand that
so
right right so the issue here would be
if operator replied
so this works because precisely operator
applied by default
considers that what follows is the
second argument no i understand that but
i'm just it's just
structurally i mean i understand the
goal of being able to pipe through a
bunch of functions
um and the fact that it would be nice if
there was a syntax
that made that really clean i mean like
like you know in a perfect world
you would be able to say um
you know slash slash let's say
you know slash tilde f slash
whatever two
but it's not obvious what's going to
happen here it's not obvious that's the
second argument
um
um well an interesting thing
okay we could we could add this to
things that we might think about about
argument
connection i mean i i have a much
grander scheme
for these uh kind of non-deterministic
argument connection
which still has to be worked on um
by the way ethan is commenting again
that tree loud is slow because of the
front and we're not saying it's slow it
won't be slow
it just it's has not yet been
implemented just because it requires
complicated plumbing
suggesting using net train as an
approximator for the
bounds of style expression that is sort
of an interesting idea
which i don't think we've explored
although i i i mean i don't know whether
that's kind of
i don't think we i don't know whether we
need to because i think it is quite fast
to find
the the actual sizes is that true or is
that is that not true is it worth having
an approximator
that works without having to go to the
front end
it depends how many cases for example
i mean it takes milliseconds at most for
one individual case but of course
in geo for example we have maps with
thousands of labels and then we don't
want to wait seconds
well i wonder whether there is an
interesting play for net train there
it's an interesting idea we haven't
considered that i mean
where basically you run actually it
sounds like a really quite good idea i
mean
we run a few tests in the front end
right to say how big are these things
showing up okay great
you i mean maybe we have a network
where we say these are the tests we ran
and we have a pre-trained network where
we feed in those
maybe it isn't even the network maybe
it's just a pure statistical type thing
where we feed in
those values and we just i'd probably
end up being a network and then we say
uh
i mean maybe the way it works is we do a
probe of you know here
are it's kind of like an interesting um
um uh kind of
um you know reinforcement learning type
story
um you know we we we find what the
optimal
test words are to ask the front end
how big are these things okay we've got
back the results for 20 test words
which takes you know uh which can happen
you know which can be cached in a
session
then given those results we can then
compute
how big any given word will be
sounds like a pretty good idea to me
does that make sense to you
we can try certainly i think it's i
think it's a good idea thank you
um
i have to dash to another meeting sorry
okay okay thank you see you
um okay
uh let's see there was
um ethan is saying it really is very
doable
we'll try it thank you thank you for
that suggestion appreciate it
um okay
okay so this is a i mean we always
discuss
at the end of a cycle this is steve is
asking
is wolverine language for arm coming yes
yes we have versions running in-house i
i think it's is it is it in 12-3
do you know it's a pity that i left
because he knows
all about that um okay sorry wrong
people
as far as i know yes oh i know what it
is i know what it is i know that i know
the chain of dependencies
the issue is um there are some trailing
things
like the machine learning framework that
are not native so you can run
under the emulator rosetta or whatever
it's called
that's fine but there are a few trailing
pieces
that are not yet native and
unfortunately you can't make an
application be native until
everything is native and um there are as
i say still
trailing pieces some of which are
actually quite hard um
but it's coming um
and rps was asking wondering if we
should have a stream every month
dedicated to simple programs exploring
their technicalities
uh
yeah well i love that stuff and we
haven't been very organized about that
and it would be an interesting thing to
do and that's for again a different
group here
and thank you for the suggestion ethan
is posting some things
um for tree layout which we should look
at thank you
um okay let's have a quick look through
this
this list of of objectives here okay so
a round got in its speed improvement for
12.3 right
uh correct yes wonderful and
yeah like a couple of orders of
magnitude and um
well that's spectacular okay
and i mean in in generic numeric
computations that should be
specific so um
right but i mean so my question there is
i mean clearly for a round the future is
making sure that it works in all the
statistics functions and things like
this
yes that's probably not that that's not
the ild team
exactly yes so that that should be
implemented by the statistics team
right um so my interest now to continue
with a round
is to make around itself uh more
powerful
and to cover the the important things
that doesn't cover yet
and and users have reported these
missing
bits so um complex numbers
sounds like a messy complicated thing
but sounds necessary
do we understand what the display would
be like
so here the idea is that right now we
are essentially using boxes
of error like it's like a linear error
in
real part an error in imaginary part
and and what users want is an ellipse so
there is correlation between uh
real and imaginary part
so what that will require is that the
second argument is a matrix
i don't understand for for a complex
number
if i say 67 plus 22i
right then what you're saying is in the
complex plane
you want this to be so and if i say
something like
um right now you can say around an
output
5 plus i something like that
and the system can't handle that so in a
sense what this is doing
is having a box a square box a
rectangular box of error
so what happens if i say complex list
plot of this
i'm not sure this is going to work okay
so
but this is because hold on actually i i
didn't give it a fair chance
okay yeah go ahead yeah so
the problem with with a box uh
description of the error is that if we
multiply by a complex number
the result is not going to be the
rotated rectangle which is what it
should be
i understand right well is it going to
be the rotated ellipsoid
once we have ellipse ellipses then we
can rotate the ellipses and then it will
work correctly
so in other words the ellipse is
specified by its major axis
and its eccentricity or something is
that right or is or it's
semi-major axes some i mean semi-major
semi-minor axis
we need three numbers which usually are
represented like the three numbers of a
symmetric real matrix
because this is a vehicle relation
really so i mean okay we're thinking
about it in terms of correlation but if
people are just thinking about it as an
i'm a little confused um but
i mean this business about combining
matrices and
era ellipses don't we already have that
issue
we have it in vector around so if we
have a 2d vector around the problem is
already there
and we can handle it okay so it's a
question of porting the vector around
stuff to
two complex numbers is that right
exactly yes exactly
okay and i mean when we so in vector
around do we do we do the
plotting correctly for vector around yes
we do
so how do i do that um
so and let's see what's an example so
you would need a vector
so what's an example here i guess in the
list plot this by the way is a bit of a
lame page if i might say so
i mean it probably should show the the
list plot
yes yeah we can do better i think
in the list plot page there are examples
under
interval markings the heck is that
at least plot
i don't understand that at all
so let's see vector around is a
two-dimensional vector
right so that would be this position one
point eight two point four
yes and then the zero three zero four
are the errors
of of each one and the zero five
is the correct what's called the
correlation factor which which
represents a matrix
now you have to give a either a matrix
or that notation which is a pair
any number okay so if i give a matrix
here
a symmetric matrix so change the
well and it has to be a correlation
matrix so
so two the non-diagonal numbers must be
small okay all right so
1.2 right point two
one correct actually let me make it just
just like point three or something oh he
said a symmetric matrix it's symmetric
it has to be symmetric
yeah a lot of constraints here
okay what does that mean
i see that's got little tentacles that
have
i don't understand what this means i
would i see i see so what this is
representing
is the um the axis
of these ellipses we are talking about
so those are the semi-axes do
interval markers go to ellipse i think
it's called
ellipses oh nice
okay but so what should we be doing by
default because i mean the other one
the other one is is what we think we're
doing the other one because we're trying
to make it look like standard error bars
right um which is probably a mistake in
this case
it's definitely going to be a pretty
confusing thing for complex numbers if
we see that
yeah so this is probably a discussion
with brett what should be the defaults
for these cases
all right but anyway complex numbers
sounds like that's not super hard
because it's just porting over
the stuff from vectors correct okay
confidence intervals what's that about
yes so this is
uh right now when we say a round of
three comma point three
it's always meaning uh the standard one
sigma
now users will want to say sometimes
these point six corresponds to three
sigma two sigma
right i understand and so this is a bit
like
this is a mixture of admitting our a
more general
input and also the representation so
that i'm not sure yet how to do it
whether we would just do the computation
to convert the input
into a single so i mean the question is
if this was the two sigma bound
right you might want some notation that
said two sigma underneath it
exactly yeah the standard thing is to
put the parenthesis and
after it and say two sigma after the
whole thing
after okay
i mean that's all well well and good for
two sigma but
maybe not so good for you know something
like this
right right it we would have to control
the the number of digits there like we
do always do in the rest of a round
perhaps 2.3
i think the the two sigma could be
really small
yep so we're really just combining this
okay okay so now the question is what's
the input what's the representation
right so i'm perhaps an option this is
something like an option that says
confidence level or
alternatively we could do something
where we say
um you know where we go something like
this
we go i don't know what that is
something arrow point three
and then uh
confidence
but it's not a confidence level what you
want is the sigma the confidence level
is something different
right because you could also have here
parent 95
confidence level right
but i mean you might want both of those
yes yes
those numbers represent the same thing
just different notations i understand
that i understand it but i'm saying that
that both in terms of input and in terms
of
i mean confidence level you know 0.95
or you might want to say is it what do
you want to say
variance or something what is the what
is the term what is
what is the number of which two what do
you call the two in two sigma
basically a variance standard deviation
no but stephen is referring this is some
sort of multiplier
so the whole thing two sigma would be
the definition
standard deviations out no no i
understand that but what that means is
this thing here represents
two standard deviations right that's
what this is this is
that's like the error value and then
we're saying what does the error value
mean
exactly and um i mean you know in a
in a very naive way we could call it
sigmas and the default is one
and the default for this is 0.68 or
whatever
right
i mean i kind of favor because i think
both of these things both confidence
level
and and sigma whatever the right term
for that is
are useful inputs right
yeah we could certainly support both and
then we then it might look like this for
example
and then whatever is given i mean if
they're inconsistent we have to deal
with that and blah blah blah blah blah
but whatever is given will determine the
output
and if we add one thing with a sigma and
another thing with the confidence level
i don't know what we get
one wins as we do in other cases fine
okay
[Music]
okay so another thing that is important
is that
is to get properties of around objects
okay and i'm here i'm not sure whether
to have an around value which is what we
had discussed long ago following
date value energy entity value
or directly with information which is
being used now in more places
should be enough to be in a round value
because i think it's too
i think information is more you've got
to blob and this is what you're getting
i think this is more
down in the details i think
i also favor that okay also because it
will be able to you
to work on things that are not directly
around like intervals
numbers from which we could get them
around i see that's a nice idea
right okay handling of just continuities
and functions
this is probably the most reported
problem with around which is
fully based on differential on
derivatives
on the first derivatives and so if you
compute things directly
on a discontinuity or something like
that
well so what else do we do about it um
well this is the case in which probably
we will have to
smoothly transition to a an interval
based approach
which i think is what users typically
expect so of course
it's very difficult to formalize in
general
okay but so the issue is you know
we're getting our error estimates from
the
derivative yes
but so this if we did finite differences
or something then we could have a
perfectly fine error estimate for a
for you know for the abs
the problem is it's not going to be
consistent because i mean the whole
calculus
of how these errors propagate is based
on
derivatives exactly that's why the the
the documents that
the guide is calculus do not specify
those cases they just say this to
non-linear
but of course users still want to handle
those no i understand that so what are
our options i mean one option is to
smooth this
somewhat i mean if if we did okay so how
much
smoothing in other words if we had a
smoothing parameter in a round
okay that said
if this is a point of discontinuity
then smooth by this amount
right so in other words if if we
literally took you know a smoothing
kernel
to abs of x that's what i'm saying yep
um and that's the definition and that's
all there is to it so to speak
and whatever you smooth you smooth so in
other words we take this
and instead of that i don't know how
will we do this how do you do a
convolutional kernel on this thing
we say do we say convolution no that
doesn't work how do we do this
you know what i'm saying i want to just
smooth it out by some
amount i think yeah i think i would
multiply by one of the windows
functions okay
but i i don't know which one to suggest
right now
it was a hamming window or something
i don't know but i i know what you mean
now there is also the problem for
example that's why i chose
abs there is also the fact that abs is
going to
move everything to the positive side so
we cannot return
around it has to be one of these
asymmetrical rounds in which the value
is
yeah that's horrifying okay but let's
try something like this
okay no it should be an x we need to put
an x somewhere i mean
let's see oh i see
ra not the right thing
um
i mean in some sense
okay go ahead there's got to be a way to
smooth this
but the problem is if we smooth it
in general it might go negative i mean
it doesn't in this case but in general
the general case of smoothing it it may
not satisfy whatever bound you think you
have
but i think that's the only kind of
honest way to do it
it's just to define it you know to have
put into the around a thing that says if
i hit a discontinuity smooth them this
way
or you think there may be something
better than that that could be done
well i mean that would be an
honest way to do it but it would depend
on how we
moved so the result is going to be
strongly dependent
okay so what would you i mean the other
possibility is essentially a table
of this function at this continuity
point does this with a round
and then i was thinking about is going
to an interval so if we change to
interval arithmetics
then we do the computations in interval
arithmetics and somehow
go back it is cheating because it
it's it's changing the rules of the game
but those rules of the game are better
defined in all cases
yeah except that's not except the errors
won't accumulate correctly if we do that
yes yes look i think a better thing to
do would be to take some of these
discontinuities
and ask the question first of all what
does we know something about what
discontinuities exist in our functions
but we've inventoried that so then the
question would be
to just ask what would we like to have
happen in each of these cases
um
and i think you know let's just try a
few different cases i mean ask
ask the function discontinuity experts
to say what they think should happen
and let's see what kinds of things
because this is you know i don't know
what happens with an essential
singularity i don't know what happens
with all kinds of other
wild things
right that's my suggestions get get the
function discontinuity people
to inventory the possible
discontinuities and say what they think
should happen
and then we'll take it from there okay
what is this so this is a discussion
that we had last week
i think it was sanders who suggested
that we do more computations for higher
moments with a round and so i was
talking to the statistics team
and they mentioned that they have all
these functions to manipulate
moments so in particular there is moment
evaluate
etc so they can handle any moment and
they have four types of moments so
central moment moment cumulative factory
moment
and so what would this do this would be
a moment of and around or what
yes exactly okay it's interesting i'm
not
quite sure all right let's just have a
quick look here
more echo functions what echo functions
have been proposed
uh no i'm just asking because this has
been a a
successful uh front in ild so i was
wondering whether there is more
to do there i don't remember i mean i i
think um
look the big thing with echo functions
is
evaluation tracing and to me there's a
bigger story to evaluation chasing
that has to do with um
you know uh
basically our kind of causal graph
formalism
can we turn that into in other words you
have an evaluation of an expression
it just does what it does but there's
also a
some kind of causal graph that
represents
what thing
what thing that is being used later in
the evaluation came from an earlier
evaluation
am i making sense and i i don't know i i
i don't have a good theory of this but i
think there's some grand
thing that we could do for evaluation
tracing i don't yet know what it is
and it's an old story right we have the
trace function that was put in in 1989
that was not very satisfactory and i'm
i'm still
trying to figure out how to do that
properly but
you should go looking whether whether
the um
um
oh boy that's a live stream from tom
notice that list plot with the round is
not saved to pdf
nicely wow that's bizarre and horrifying
really that it's not a vector graphic
that really surprises me
but we should look at that yes
yeah thanks for the suggestion it may be
some particular
one of the um uh you know interval
markers
would have that characteristic
um okay just just
go ahead and that's coordinate is just a
function that i always wanted to have
but
i don't get to to finish it so what is
it
so it's a function that receives
an array of data and ranges
of coordinates and it's able to insert
the positions
as a rule or something
in various ways we can specify whether
it's a pair or or a flat
list or an association or a rule yeah i
agree this will be a useful function
i mean the default version of it
presumably would give part numbers for
instance
exactly yeah but you can specify ranges
or dates you could insert dates it could
work with your positions
right so it's the thing that goes from a
plain positional list
to a thing that has coordination which
is why it's called attached
i mean i mean i'm wondering whether you
know
whether the term coordinates
court
is that an interesting word or does that
scare us from physics
i i would love it okay
fine all right well okay if you think it
means the right thing um
i think that's an interesting word for
this
it's more it it
somehow is a bit more evocative than the
attach
thing all right we should probably wrap
up here
um for those interested i in fact have
another live stream in 10 minutes
about uh history of science and
technology
um so that's that's more in the
in the hobby channel um all right
good stuff and it's um uh we got lots
more of these to go through right
hundreds and hundreds which which which
month are we at
so far are we this is february we're
almost through march in our
um of which year um
19 the months get shorter though all
right 19
wait wait no no no it's in the 2000s
2019
yeah yeah okay that 19.
okay fine um after that the months get
shorter though
like 23 days each or something
because they're less functions yeah okay
well at least less functions that make
it into this
you know the low hanging fruit came
early basically
that too so okay yeah the
the percentage might drop and the raw
number
of candidates drops right
okay sounds good all right well
good stuff